[Music]
he was impossible to ignore Silvio
Berlusconi was a giant figure in Italian
life for decades on end in politics
business Sport and on the global stage
he played the game into his 80s part of
the Coalition that won Italy's last
general election and pushed Georgia
Maloney into power
he was a man who was never afraid to
defend his beliefs and it was exactly
that courage and determination that made
him one of the most influential men in
the history of Italy that allowed him to
make real turning points in the world of
politics communication in the world of
business with him Italy learned that he
should never have limits imposed Italy
learned that it should never give up
his death was not a surprise but it
still felt like a shock to many
today I'm in pain he's like a family
member he's given me something all my
life but today I cannot think about
tomorrow
from the center right Berlusconi LED
four separate governments spending more
time as prime minister than any other
post-war Italian politician we find
but it was never straightforward he was
cited in dozens of criminal
investigations mostly around claims of
fraud
trouble followed him Berlusconi was
convicted of paying a Moroccan dance of
a sex when she was just 17 years old at
one of his lavish bunga bunga parties
but he won an appeal and laughed off the
Scandal bunga bunga even became a
catchphrase then came a conviction for
tax fraud that he couldn't beat
Berlusconi was at his lowest ebb and
protested furiously on one of his own TV
stations in exchange for the commitment
I have made over almost 20 years in
favor of my country and coming almost at
the end of my public life I received as
a reward accusations and a verdict that
is founded on absolutely amazing it
takes away my personal freedom and my
political rights but he was blessed with
an infectious smile Rolling Stone
magazine once named him their rock star
of the year
[Music]
lifted and gleaming his smile he never
retired from public life campaigning and
Charming to the end
Berlusconi was a showman a politician
who lived for the spotlight
Alex Rossi Sky News Milan